let's finish cleanly but also
aggressively what to play let's play
with us last time
ooh budapest declined a three Jerome
Jerome time let's go the the Jerome
meets the Budapest this is probably just
terrible
no one should try at home but I mean the
ideas Queen Queen h4 King f3 okay Jerome
would be proud
the question is how do i punish this
move
I mean Queen h4 does g3 maybe does this
move just reinforce the night this is my
sweater say it says eros --n o people e
rosen as my art team hoodie uniform ok
have to bring in more pieces the knight
can't do the job alone g3 was actually a
good move though aligning with the king
in how many hours in the rematch with
hairy man you're making me do math it's
like two and a half days 24 plus 24 plus
18
I kept like g5
yeah g5 let's go I'm threatening the
fork I'm also a threatening connect for
this is very close to mate but it's not
quite mate oh there's a cool line
there's a really cool line King has to
move here f4 oh no my night my night
it's undefended in the center ok this is
also for if the King or to take it if
the King were to take it there was
Bishop f5 meat that was it in so sweet
this is also sweet it's like winning a
queen and maybe the rook let's take a
look ween
and I'd see five will come yeah the
choker match is Thursday 3:00 p.m.
Central Time us
that's play Bishop c2 we'll both be
streaming it's there will be a delay
it'll also be covered on the chest 24 or
YouTube channel
I should probably prepare for it this
was a budapest gambit inspired by the
jerome gambit but Knight takes off to is
now a movie should or was a yeah it was
Bishop f2 no other movie you should try
at home
yeah so the plan is to mate along this
diagonal I don't think I can really do
much about it unless 94 but okay there's
gonna be unlike the previous games it's
it's nice being up material figure out
how satisfying it is squishy squishy is
back someday
but openings are not really created
they're discovered I don't mean to get
too philosophical